there are 87 fewer billionaires in the
world in 2022 according to forbes while
countries like russia and china are
shedding billionaires four countries got
their first ever billionaires over the
past year
barbados bulgaria estonia and uruguay
there is now at least one billionaire in
75 countries
here are the nations that got their
first member of the three comma club
this year
barbados
rihanna may be most famous for her
musical career but it's her 50 stake in
cosmetics brand fenty beauty which she
co-owns with luxury conglomerate lvmh
that earned her a spot among the
billionaires she owns an estimated 30 of
the savagex fenty lingerie line which
raised 125 million dollars in january
and is now reportedly weighing an ipo at
a 3 billion valuation
bulgaria
georgie and kirill domochev got their
start selling locally manufactured
clothes and shoes after the fall of
communism in sofia bulgaria in the 1990s
later they joined forces with a group of
undisclosed investors to acquire newly
privatized companies that had been
state-owned the brothers started
investing alone in 2000 when they bought
54 of partially state-owned animal
health firm biovet they eventually
purchased the company outright and
transformed it into juve pharma now the
world's sixth largest livestock health
firm with operations stretching from
lincoln nebraska to northwestern italy
their other holdings range from bulk
cargo shipping to ludogorets rasgrad
which became the country's most
successful soccer team under their
ownership
estonia
christo carmen and his fellow estonian
co-founders set up wise then known as
transferwise in london in 2011 when the
two decided they were quote sick of
losing their money to their banks each
time they sent money to their native
estonia
now the firm processes nearly eight
billion dollars in cross-border payments
each month for its 12 million customers
across 52 countries
when wise went public in london in july
2021 carmen's 19 stake was worth 2
billion
the stock fell by 39 from then through
march 11th the day forbes finalized
valuations for the 2022 world's
billionaires list
uruguay
andrei saroki and sergio fogle teamed up
in 2009 to launch astropay a payments
firm that helps consumers in emerging
markets store funds online using a
prepaid virtual debit card
in 2016 they helped co-found d-local
which helps large multinational firms
including amazon netflix uber and
microsoft to handle cross-border
payments from customers in 35 emerging
markets
d-local became uruguay's first unicorn
in september 2020 when the firm raised
200 million dollars at a 1.2 billion
dollar valuation and went public on the
nasdaq in june 2021
you